Donald Trump yesterday took a fiasco field
trip to Texas to brag, I guess, about Corona
virus and also to brag about how he's supporting
coal and oil and fracking. All things we should
actually be making obsolete rather than trying
to do more of. It was really the stuff of
nightmares. I'm going to run through it. I
watched it live so that you didn't have to,
although about 20000 people did. Watch it
live with me on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
But here are some of the lowlights. And again,
this is just a reminder that we can not have
this in the White House. This has to be cleansed.
I don't know if we can use Bleacher Isopropyl
to cleanse it, but we we somehow do need to
remove this. Now, if you're watching along
with me, you're going to notice in these videos
that Donald Trump is particularly sweaty and
extra orange. It is Texas, after all. And
I understand it was very, very hot there.
It's become super clear to me that psychologically
these events were Trump, you know, will tour
a factory or a business, and then he'll rant
to a hand-picked group of sycophants. These
have become sort of place holders for the
big rallies that Trump would like to be doing
to boost his ego, but he can't realistically
do right now because of the virus. Now, Donald
Trump did have one of what I would call these
major glitches where he interrupts a word
right in the middle of the word and sort of
has to reset his brain. It happened in the
middle of a word I actually can't identify.
Maybe you can.
Let's take a look now at the strongest point
militarily we've ever been due to talk to
you.
Ted, where is Ted? He was a big leader in
the stand up again.
Ted, these glitches have become very frequent
recently, but only one such glitch during
yesterday's event. Donald Trump later complained
that Joe Biden's climate plan is too aggressive,
which is like, well, that's great, let's let's
be aggressive. I want to see that. And during
this part of the rant, Donald Trump referred
to the year 2030, which is a milestone year
for Joe Biden's climate plan.
He referred to it as the year to 30, which
is, of course, a long time ago seeking an
even higher level of restrictions, mandating
that zero carbon emissions, which frankly
is impossible for all new homes, offices and
buildings by two 30, not possible to do. And
have you ever did it? It would cause so much
that your home would be valueless.
As I listened to Trump rattle off what Biden
wants to do, I'm reassured by it. I think
that's great. Let's try to do it. Maybe we
can't. But I want to be you know, Trump is
doing the opposite. Trump's rolling back restrictions
on polluting. He's rolling back vehicle emissions,
vehicle efficiency and emissions standards
emissions. See, I kind of like that portmanteau.
I want a guy who maybe is going to try to
do too much and maybe we don't we don't get
there, but let's try to do it. Trump criticizing
that. Donald Trump also praised Texans during
this event as loving America so much that
they couldn't breathe. Which is kind of weird
imagery, given everything that's going on
with the I can't breathe protests and what
happened with George Floyd being choked to
death. Let's take a look at this bizarre moment.
Generations of Texas oil workers before you
gave every last bit of sweat and heart and
grit that they had to build up this country.
They loved our country. They loved our country
so much they couldn't breathe.
Donald Trump also kept accusing Joe Biden
in recent weeks of dementia. Here again, Donald
Trump couldn't even say Minneapolis very quickly,
just like we did in Minneapolis.
And just like we will do another place.
So many Anapolis Ulysses S. Grant talking
about plasma instead of plasma. Trump's having
no shortage of problems himself. And then
maybe the most sort of notable policy related
claim that Trump made yesterday is, again,
this just ridiculous talking point that Joe
Biden wants to end the suburbs. But Donald
Trump is going to save them. And this is actually
just the dog whistle stuff we've become accustomed
to. I'll explain it after we look at the clip.
That's not going to happen.
And by the way, I just ended the rule on suburbs.
You know, the suburbs will fight all of their
lives to get into the suburbs and have a beautiful
home. There will be no more low income housing
forced in to the suburbs. I abandoned that,
took away and just rescinded the rule. It's
been going on for years. I've seen conflict
for years.
It's been hell for suburbia. We rescinded
the rule three days ago. So enjoy your life.
Ladies and gentlemen, enjoy your life.
So this is really bad. It's first of all.
This is a racially tinged dog whistle. No
low income people invading the suburbs is
reminiscent of the black folks moving in next
door, stuff of the 1950s and 60s and prior
eras. It's just complete racially tinged red
meat for his followers. Secondly, Trump doesn't
even really seem to understand what he did.
He says he rescinded a rule. Now what he's
talking, he doesn't even know what he's talking
about. But I'll tell you what he's talking
about. There's a 2015 rule, the affirmatively
furthering fair housing rule. OK. F a f f
h. And it requires local governments, if they're
getting federal funding, they have to study
racial bias in housing patterns and have a
plan to address it. That's all. Like, it's
so milquetoast. It's so almost nothing. If
you get money, you have to study racial bias
in housing. And if you determine there is
racial bias, you have to address it. That's
all it does. And Trump is now claiming to
be some kind of hero for rescinding it. It's
just racist red meat. That's all it is. And
Trump tweeted something similar earlier in
the day about it, widely derided as despicable,
saying, quote, I am happy to inform all of
the people living their suburban lifestyle.
Dream capitalized, by the way, that you will
no longer be bothered. Or financially hurt
by having low income housing built in your
neighborhood, your housing prices will go
up based on the market and crime will go down.
I have rescinded the Obama Biden a f f h rule.
Enjoy. This is complete and total red meat.
He has now gone on to say we should look at
delaying the presidential election. This is
an ignorant, delusional, narcissistic, authoritarian
nightmare. There is very little more to say.
It just has to end in November. We've all
got a vote that we know the solution we don't
have. You know, it's not like one of these
complex problems where we say, you know, we've
identified a problem, but figuring out a solution
is really tough. We're going to. What what
could we possibly do? Voting starts in four
and a half weeks in some states were three
months almost to the day. If you did three
months plus a few days from the we we know
what to do. We have the solution. There is
no greater power than having a problem and
knowing the solution. Let's now actually carry
it out. Make sure you're following the David
Pakman. Show it on Instagram at David Pakman
show and follow me on Instagram at David Dot
Pacman. Check out recent pictures of completely
safe, socially distant beach going that I
did.
Shocking to many people. Yes, I do have legs,
although they are not ever visible during
the show. Follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman for a break from the bad news, as I
like
to say.